I don't understand how songwriters come
up with a riff
you know like one of your iconic riffs
you come up with a riff
how do you know what to sing over and
does it all start with the Riff yes it
definitely starts at the Riff for me as
a vocalist I try to insert where the
guitar isn't at times you know we'll do
uh you know like say a man for instance
and the verse is
you simplify for riff so the vocal has
its place to jump around you know Kirk
came up with that riff I know I've read
like three in the morning Kirk you're
laying in bed and you heard that kind of
Rift and I know Lars then said to you
why don't you do this and this and this
to the Riff but play the original riff
Kirk that you came up with before you
even showed it to James literally Howard
is at three o'clock in the morning and I
played it like this
thank you
[Music]
and
then he came up to me
and said repeat the first part three
times and then play the chords
afterwards or four times whatever it is
and so I say okay
[Music]
that so yeah the back the back one is
the tail the front one is you know
whatever yeah three repeats and then a
tail and then you have a workable riff
Lars doesn't know how to play guitar and
he will arrange stuff and he'll just say
hey can't you do that thing in another
key something that I wouldn't do you
know like Sam and for instance
then change the key
it's like I I wouldn't do that I I can't
pick that and then it'll be a challenge
it's like okay I can do that so there's
there's a lot of um pushing of each
other you know same with like drum stuff
too exactly yeah like James hey can't
you do this thing there and it's like I
would never have thought of that and yes
I can try that give me a day and I'll
come back and it'll be worked out but
the main thing thankfully with this
bunch of guys is that when we go into a
songwriting situation we leave our egos
outside and it's not uh it's my guitar
don't tell me what to play oh it's I'm
the drummer you know you know just stay
away you know it's like James well how
about this part how about that I wanted
to try it on the toms of course and I'll
throw stuff back to James go why don't
you try this try a different key why
don't you down pick it but instead of
trying to Galloping it or try to go
chugs instead of double picking or
whatever and that there's that freedom
because there's trust and when those
whenever there's the love and then you
know you're you're not there's nothing
that's gonna happen by getting into
everybody's each other's stuff that's
gonna affect the relationships and and
that's a great thing
foreign